truffle hunting first of all this dude
it's dude man he's a singer-songwriter
who the Truffle Hunter okay look at the
goddamn hell you tired the lead truffle
hunter dog
uh do you hunt them with a gun
so so where dude yeah yeah that's the
American way yeah yeah you pull out a
[ __ ] yeah you pull out an AR and you
have a kid hold the mushroom
thank you you take the trouble oops
oh my God I had I haven't said anything
I haven't said anything [ __ ] up in
like 10 days okay I'm pent up dude yeah
fair I'm gonna make the most you didn't
use that joke in your vows yeah dude
that's a good one oh dude oh man I was
[ __ ] around at the altar too just to
anything to hide the crying but we'll
get there okay
so we learned a lot about truffle
hunting but first of all let's start
with the Truffle Hunter himself uh this
man's name is Julio Julio the Truffle
Hunter should you ever be in Italy go
with this man
[Music]
you take that picture no no okay no that
definitely ain't him so where we're
staying it's like this is this Villa
it's like in the countryside of Italy
and in the morning we could hear
gunshots from people like hunting I
think it was their lunch maybe or like
something they're gonna eat later but
all in the morning we're just here
damn I'm setting the tone so with the
Truffle Hunter
we walk two three minutes and there's a
side road with like a chain and he just
lifts it up he's like okay
we're like where the [ __ ] have we gone
we started walking down this
was like a fire Road or something it's
pretty muddy it's wet and so we learned
that with truffle hunting they used to
use pigs but the pigs [ __ ] up the
forest okay so now they gotta use these
dogs okay they're like Burmese or I
don't know what they are they're dirty
as hell though these dogs are matted
I don't think they the dogs that uh they
use yeah those are a boy I think that's
his main [ __ ] like she passed and rest
in peace so these dogs are like matted
and muddy from just hunting for troubles
you know that's nothing against them but
when they start jumping on
your leg and [ __ ] you're like hey
I came from La man these are some nice
threads
let's chill out man I'm hunting in
designer you know
you're in the land of the designer there
yeah true
so one of these dogs to really set the
tone it pees on one of my family members
legs
like just pulls up pulls up okay and
treats this person like a like a fire
fire hydrant okay leg up and just blast
yeah this person yeah and I gotta lay
down some dominance
yeah right away yeah who's the alpha
here dog well he let us know yeah and my
family member they just stood there
let the piss happen and then she goes
yeah it just peed on me
and she walked back to the villa
so she did not join for that particular
event damn yeah holy [ __ ] yeah and Julio
was you know he's it's a group of like
it happens there's a group of like 25.
Seinfeld
this is gonna happen this is gonna be
the episode you just trying to do an
Italian accent yeah it was Seinfeld
wasn't it
you know
summertimes of the dogapee
the dog peed on me
you know and Julio he's just kind of
distracted there's a lot of people and
he's got his boy Mauro and that guy oh
man that dude will find a truffle in
your own ass that dude could just pull
you on your back lift your leg up and be
like hey
Maga his dog's name was Maga okay maga
maga okay yeah Mago you know and then
he'd whatever
so you know I'm kind of expecting we're
going to be crawling up hillsides and
stuff you know looking at the base of
trees which you were but I thought it
was going to be this sort of
national treasure moment where everyone
goes quiet
you know
nah no these dogs are like bats out of
hell they're just all over the grounds
then they find a hole and their tail
starts wagging and they hit it with a
hatchet who uh
oh Jesus yeah Charlie hunting is really
fun
no so like Julia or that other dude will
run over and they'd hit the ground with
a hatchet hack it to pieces
they get in there and they they just
pull out this little turd they'd be like
hey I'm like that's it like yeah that's
it they're just going all over the
ground just finding these little dirt
nuggets in the ground
and it was a really
um
it was a really streamlined process we
found a [ __ ] ton really yeah and we're
like oh did you eat them yeah like you
had them on pasta or whatever after oh
so here's the best part
we had a truffle salad
which was truffle Flakes and pieces of
bread okay
okay and then just like some oil okay no
lettuce
no no it was a salad okay it's bread and
truffle right I was dying they're like
this is a truffle salad and I'm like
it was the green though in Italy y'all
don't [ __ ] with green it's like you you
had it on the flag and then you left it
there it does it's not in the food
rarely it's in the food so anyway
so we hunt the Truffles and go back eat
them cool then towards the end of the
dinner our boy is like hey I'm an artist
too
and he sings oh okay and he puts on hit
like he puts on some hits from his album
Julio Julio okay this boy is singing was
he singing about truffles oh yeah really
oh any any brought his lady out
can you sing
it's the only word I remember you really
did that yeah yeah he was singing to a
row of 25 people I mean you gotta you
gotta write about what you know so yeah
kind of makes sense no it was Genuine
Music
I mean yeah that's that's rougher
sort of when the dog sniffs that
that's a tough
nailed it man yeah that's exactly how he
sounded okay good yeah he's not offended
at all
so you know that that was kind of you
know all right this is what we're in for
uh and then the jet lag hit me and I
slept through the first hour of our
welcome party okay okay that's good I
woke up and Elena's fully ready
face done
she's like hey
everyone's waiting I'm like what are you
talking about they downstairs
I'm starting to get ready
she's like you gotta like speed it up
I'm like we're good it's fine she's like
it's 8 30. we're supposed to have a
sunset dinner
it's [ __ ] pitch black outside
I kind of put on my suit and I cracked
the blinds there's a whole table out on
this Terrace everyone's just standing
around like
oh no I'm like oh it's outside damn
my bad
it's like late to his own wedding yeah I
know it's a naturally I get out there
I'm like it wouldn't be me if
and then uh everyone's like huh yeah
yeah they're like yeah we're hungry as
[ __ ] yeah dude
so we went inside we had a little uh
casino night that that kind of like
smoothed things over
I you know I've never seen people be
conservative with play money really oh
yeah
you know my dad when it comes to money
he's like he's tight [ __ ]
and I'm sitting there I'm like just
throw it all in he's like I don't know
I'm gonna think about it I'm like
pushing this chips I'm like just just do
it he's like no no no hey hey hey hey no
not now and then Elena's dad he was like
trying to play poker seriously and he'd
like wait and wait till he got a good
hand and he got a good hand you throw a
little chips in I'm like oh you like
what you got and I just push a stack
over and he'd be like he'd like slam his
cards he's like you always do that
like just have fun with it it's fine
you're a poor sport yeah
everyone called me a sore winner